Dragonriders, dreamers, and dragonknights.
The Targaryen dynasty ruled for centuries,
but who conquered, and who was deemed "unworthy"?
We’re climbing the branches of one of
the messiest family trees in Westeros.
During House of the Dragon, the Targaryens
rule Westeros. But they have more humble
origins than their wealth and dragons suggest,
and aren't even from the western continent. The
family can trace its roots back to Valyria,
the one-time capital city of the Freehold in
Essos. As King Viserys explains to Alicent
Hightower, Valyria was a city so great,
the world hadn't seen its equal in the century
since its destruction. In The World of Ice & Fire,
George R. R. Martin points out how
the Targaryens were among dozens of
dragon-riding families who called Valyria
home, but they weren't a major power.
While their mass exodus was seen as an act of
weakness, only three houses escaped Valyria
before it was destroyed: the Targaryens, the
Velaryons, and the Celtigars. They survived
because of the visions of Daenys Targaryen — also
known as Daenys the Dreamer — which prophesied
the fiery downfall of their civilization.
Her father, Aenar, had uprooted his people
and fled about 12 years before the Doom fell
on Valyria, which included Daenys' brother,
Gaemon. Gaemon married Daenys and ruled as Lord of
Dragonstone after his father. For about 70 years,
Targaryens remained at Dragonstone and
continued wedding sisters to brothers.
Aegon Targaryen is clearly the most important
figure in Martin's fantastical fictional history.
This second child of Lord Aerion Targaryen
would marry both his older sister, Visenya,
and his younger sister, Rhaenys. Though it
is believed that Aegon married Visenya out
of expectation and Rhaenys because he was smitten.
He first sired the child Aenys with Rhaenys. His
child with Visenya — named Maegor— came along
five years later. But before there was a crown
and a throne for either of them to inherit, Aegon
had to earn his nickname and do some conquering.
"Say what you will about the Targaryens, they
were conquerors. That is a seat for a conqueror."
The full story of Aegon's conquest of the Seven
Kingdoms of Westeros could fill several seasons
of another Game of Thrones prequel series. House
of the Dragon adds a motivation for Aegon's
conquest besides raw ambition: He had a dream
about a coming threat from the North which he
etched into the blade of the catspaw
dagger he inherited from his ancestor,
Lord Aenar. Aegon believed that
only a Targaryen king or queen
with dragons was formidable enough
to face whatever danger was to come.
There's bound to be tension in a love
triangle. It was no different with Aegon,
Visenya, Rhaenys, and their children. Since the
king preferred the company of his younger wife,
he kept Rhaenys and Aenys
with him at King's Landing,
while Visenya and Maegor lived at Dragonstone.
The two princes had little in common and didn't
care for each other. Aenys was undersized
and sickly, which spurred rumors that he
wasn't actually Aegon's son. But he grew up to
be a dreamer and a dragonrider like his father,
possessing gifts that Aegon did not. He was
charming, sociable, talented, and clever.
When Aegon died of a stroke around age 64,
Aenys hurried on his dragon Quicksilver to
the funeral and was declared the next king. In a
political calculation, he bequeathed his father's
ancestral sword, Blackfyre, to his half-brother
Maegor and suggested they'd rule together. He
knew Maegor — who was an enormous warrior
without an equal — would be a better ally
than an enemy. The King's personal life was
fruitful, having six children with his wife,
Alyssa Velaryon. But his reign was not. After five
years of rebellions and assassination attempts,
Aenys died — with some believing that
Visenya and Maegor orchestrated his death.
Maegor was almost the inverse of his
half-brother, taking six wives but having
no surviving children. While he is responsible
for completing much of the construction of
King's Landing, his burning of the Sept of
Remembrance, mass executions of builders,
and general oppression of Westeros' people
earned him the nickname Maegor the Cruel.
Maegor was found dead of mysterious
circumstances on the Iron Throne. He
had no heir, so the succession passed to
Aenys and Alyssa's oldest surviving son,
Jaehaerys. The Faith of the Seven — the dominant
religion in Westeros — had risen against Aenys
when he betrothed his children, Rhaena and
Aegon, to each other. The siblings were later
killed. Following in his family's tradition, the
new 14-year-old King Jaehaerys wanted to marry
his sister Alysanne. His mother Alyssa tried
to forbid it, fearing a war with the church.
"I serve the gods. The gods demand justice."
"How do they communicate their
demands? By raven or horse?"
But the King would get his way, wedding Alysanne
in secret. When he instituted the "Doctrine of
Exceptionalism" when he came of age, he ensured
that only Targaryen royals could enter into
sibling marriages. He made peace with Maegor's few
remaining loyalists by restoring their titles and
lands, so long as they recognized his legitimacy.
Jaehaerys and Alysanne were almost always together
throughout his prosperous 45-year dynasty. Though
Jaehaerys was one of the Seven Kingdoms' most
effective rulers, his long life and legendary
fertility created the conditions for civil war.
Of Jaehaerys and Alysanne's 13 children, only
one survived their father's reign. The king and
queen's first, 11th, and 12th children died in
infancy, while their 2nd, 6th, 10th, and 13th met
their ends in a variety of ways in their teenage
years. Their 8th child, Daella, reached adulthood
but passed away during a difficult labor. Their
9th, Saera, was a troubled girl who ran away to
Volantis where she operated a pleasure house and
bore many illegitimate children — she wasn't heard
from again. As King Jaehaerys reached old
age, just 4 of his offspring remained alive
and at court: his 3rd child, Aemon, his 4th,
Baelon, his 5th, Alyssa, and his 7th, Vaegon.
Jaehaerys named Aemon his heir and Prince
of Dragonstone. Baelon and Alyssa married
each other. Vaegon became an archmaester. The
succession seemed secure until Aemon was killed
in battle during a conflict in Myr. He left behind
a wife, Lady Jocelyn Baratheon, and a daughter,
Rhaenys Targaryen — who had recently married
Corlys Velaryon. Baelon was made the new Prince
of Dragonstone. His sister-wife, Princess Alyssa,
had perished giving birth to their third child
after their sons Viserys and Daemon were born,
leaving Jaehaerys and Alysanne with two surviving
heirs. Then Baelon succumbed to appendicitis
just five days later. House of the Dragon
insinuates that Otto Hightower may have plotted
the Prince's death to advance his own position,
but in the end, Vaegon was the single
Targaryen child to outlive King Jaehaerys.
Baelon's death caused a Westerosi crisis. The
King's advisors and the Lords of the Realm all
agreed that Vaegon wasn't a viable candidate for
the crown, as he was unpopular and disinterested
in leadership. Only two were considered
reasonable: Aemon's grandson Laenor Velaryon, and
Baelon aand Alyssa's son Viserys. King Jaehaerys
convened what's known as the Great Council of 101
AC at Harrenhal, where a thousand lords took six
months to gather and decide who should succeed the
long-reigning king. Though Aemon was the older
prince and Rhaenys thought his line should have
the stronger claim, the lords chose Viserys as
he was 24 years in age, compared to Laenor's
7 years — though in House of the Dragon, they
choose Viserys over Rhaenys because he is male.
"Men would sooner put the realm to the torch,
than see a woman ascend the Iron Throne."
But the Council's vote didn't resolve the
succession with as much finality that the
King had hoped for. Viserys ascended the Iron
Throne two years later when Jaehaerys died in
his sleep. Around the time Viserys' wife Aemma
died in childbirth. As a result, he named his
daughter Rhaenyra as his heir and Princess of
Dragonstone. This angered his brother Daemon,
who coveted the title and assumed he'd follow
his brother as the next Targaryen king. Though
he remained supportive of Rhaenyra's claim to
the Iron Throne, Viserys took a second wife,
Alicent Hightower, with whom he had four more
children: Aegon, Helaena, Aemond, and Daeron.
King Viserys insisted Rhaenyra marry Laenor
Velaryon. Though their union was a political
arrangement — with Laenor preferring the company
of men — they produced three children: Jacaerys,
Lucerys, and Joffrey Velaryon. In truth,
however, these boys were likely the sons of
Ser Harwin Strong, Rhaenyra's rumored lover and
Captain of the Gold Cloaks. All three resembled
the man known as Breakbones with their bulky
physiques, broad noses, and brown hair. This
complicated Rhaenyra's legitimacy in the eyes
of some at court and among some common folk.
They believed that if her sons were illegitimate,
they had no business sitting on the Iron Throne.
Though Rhaenyra and Daemon were rivals on paper,
they always enjoyed a close relationship. Around
the same time she wed Laenor, Daemon — free
to marry again after the death of his first
wife — married Laenor's sister Laena. The
happy dragon-riding couple had twin daughters,
Baela and Rhaena, before Laena died laboring
with their stillborn son. Shortly thereafter,
Laenor was allegedly killed
in a fight with his companion.
Before the customary mourning period was
over, Rhaenyra and Daemon exchanged vows
without King Viserys' permission. They
would have two fully Targaryen sons,
Aegon and Viserys. Since Rhaenyra's claim
was tenuous despite her father's decree and
the lords' oaths, so was the position
of her five sons. Those who supported
her line were called the Blacks.
In the books, this is a reference
to a dress the Princess wore at her father
and Alicent's fifth anniversary celebration.
The rivals of the Blacks were the Greens —
so named for Queen Alicent's green gown. The
Greens backed Viserys and Alicent's firstborn
son, though Aegon's only claim was that he
was male and Rhaenyra was not. Thanks to
his grandfather and mother's statecraft,
the Greens were able to win young Aegon many
allies. Alicent married her son to his sister,
Halaena, and the teenage bride quickly became
pregnant with twins, whom she named Jaehaerys
and Jaehaera. While the couple would later
welcome another son — Maelor— Aegon was
thought to have depraved sexual appetites and
possibly sired many more illegitimate children.
"Think of the shame on your
wife. On me. How can you keep
carrying on like this?
Especially on a day like today."
Because the Greens remained at King's Landing
while the Blacks were often found at Dragonstone,
Alicent and Aegon were privy to the
news of the death of King Viserys
first. Aegon II was installed as the new
king before word reached Princess Rhaenyra,
who crowned herself in a separate ceremony in
response to her half-brother's treason. Aegon
II would rule over a kingdom in a civil
war for about two years. The scheming and
dragon battles between the Greens and the
Blacks resulted in the deaths of Aegon's
sister-wife Halaena and his three sons.
With his defeat seeming imminent, Aegon II
was poisoned by a group of conspirators at his
court, likely to prevent any further cruelty.
Peace finally returned to the realm with the
ascension of King Aegon III. While Rhaenyra and
Daemon both died during the Dance of Dragons — as
did her sons Jacaerys, Lucerys, and Joffrey — her
children with Daemon, Aegon and Viserys, survived.
Jaehaera, the daughter of Aegon II and Halaena,
also survived. While these cousins were sworn
enemies, they eventually married each other. For
five years, Aegon III was too young to rule and
a group of regents worked to mend the kingdom's
divisions. However, the king could not be mended
after the trauma he'd witnessed and experienced,
becoming known as Aegon the Unlucky,
Aegon the Unhappy, and Aegon the Broken.
Jaehaera suffered invisible wounds
from the Dance as well. She threw
herself from a window before she and her
cousin-husband could consummate the match,
thus ending the genetic line of the Greens. Aegon
III took Daenaera Velaryon as his second wife,
and she gave him five children. After a 25-year
reign, Aegon III died of consumption at only 36
years old. His sons, Daeron and Baelor, became the
next two Targaryen kings, but both of their stints
on the throne were cut short by their own fatal
flaws. Daeron was killed trying to conquer Dorne,
before he could produce heirs. Baelor was a
religious fanatic who remained celebate even after
he was married to his sister, Daena. He eventually
died because of a self-imposed hunger strike.
Daemon and Rhaenyra's second son, Viserys, had
been Hand to the last three monarchs, so he was
well-prepared for the job when he became the 10th
Targaryen King. King Viserys II was more like his
great-great-grandfather, Jaehaerys, rather than
his namesake. He was an excellent communicator and
reformer that improved life throughout Westeros.
He established a central bank, expanded freedoms,
and improved trade relations, all within his
first year on the Iron Throne. Unfortunately, it
was his only year on the throne: Viserys II died
unexpectedly at age 50 due to a sudden illness.
"The sickness struck him
very hard. And very fast. "
Rhaenyra and Daemon's last child continued their
line with Targaryen children of his own — Aemon,
Aegon, and Naerys — born of his wife Larra Rogare.
Aemon became a member of the Kingsguard and went
down in history as the legendary Dragonknight.
King Aegon IV succeeded his father as king,
married his sister Naerys, and cemented his
legacy as Aegon the Unworthy — a corrupt and
hedonistic monarch, surrounded with yes men and
mistresses, who plunged the kingdoms into ruin.
His uncontrollable lust led him to father at least
13 illegitimate children, while only producing two
trueborn children with Queen Naerys — Daeron and
Daenerys. Worst of all, Aegon IV is suspected
of having poisoned his own father, Viserys
II, to hasten his ascension to the throne.
Aegon the Unworthy caused chaos even after
his disastrous reign. Before he died from
his own sloth and gluttony, he legitimized his
bastards and bequeathed the ancestral sword
Blackfyre to his eldest, Daemon Waters. Aegon
IV resented his trueborn son Daeron and began
a rumor that the prince was really the love
child of his brother, Aemon the Dragonknight,
and his sister-wife Naerys, in an attempt
to undermine Daemon's succession claim.
Daemon renamed himself Daemon Blackfyre and
gathered an army to oppose the new King Daeron II.
Thus, the Targaryens and the Kingdoms were torn
apart by a second and longer civil war. Daeron
was popular with some Westerosi lords because
he was everything his father was not — cultured,
diplomatic, just — and he had finally united
Dorne with the rest of Westeros through his
marriage to Myriah Martell. Others sided with
Daemon Blackfyre, as there was still animosity
toward Dorne after so many losses there. They
thought Daemon's possession of Blackfyre, his
father's final decree, and his military
prowess made him the stronger claimant.
In total, there would be five Blackfyre
Rebellions over the course of half a
century. Daeron II was succeeded by his son
Aerys I, who had no heirs, and Maekar I — who
had six children with his wife Dyanna Dayne:
Daeron, Aerion, Aemon, Daella, Aegon, and Rhae.
The story of Maekar's children
is told in Martin's anthology,
A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms. Maekar's
eldest son, Daeron the Dreamer — or Daeron
the Drunk — was tormented by prophetic visions
and died of pox. His second son, Aerion,
believed himself to be a dragon in human form,
and accidentally took his own life by drinking
wildfire — hoping it would reveal his "true" form.
This left Maekar's third son, Aemon, next in line,
except he had become a maester. Another Great
Council was convened with the questions:
Should Aemon be released from his vows?
Or should Aegon — Maekar's fourth son,
who had been living as a peasant with the
knight Ser Duncan — be crowned instead?
"The gods were cruel when
they saw fit to test my vows."
They shouldn't have bothered, as Aemon abdicated
the Iron Throne and banished himself to the Wall
so that he couldn't be used against his brother.
King Aegon V became the 15th Targaryen king,
reigning for nearly 25 years over a
kingdom that was intermittently at
war with the Blackfyres. He'd married Betha
Blackwood of his own accord years earlier,
and they had five children: Duncan, Jaehaerys,
Shaera, Daeron, and Rhaelle. This king and queen
wanted to move away from the Targaryen tradition
of incestual marriage, and arranged marriages for
their children with the other great Westerosi
houses, like the Baratheons and the Tullys.
Duncan renounced the throne to marry
a peasant named Jenny of Oldstones,
while Jaehaerys and Shaera married each
other. King Jaehaerys II would succeed his
father after the Tragedy at Summerhall in which
Aegon V, Duncan, and many others were killed.
This reportedly occurred when the king tried to
hatch dragon eggs, setting the palace on fire.
Jaehaerys II and Shaera had two children of
their own: Aerys and Rhaella. Though they
had wed for passion, they joined their
son and daughter together against King
Aegon V's wishes due to a witch's prophecy.
The witch predicted that the fabled Prince
Who Was Promised would come from their union.
Knowing what we now know about Aegon I's dream,
this was likely a stronger motivating
factor for Jaehaerys, rather than tradition.
Jaehaerys II died of illness, and Aerys II
ascended to the throne. He and his sister-wife
Rhaelle had three children — Rhaegar, Viserys,
and Daenerys— but lost many more to miscarriage
and stillbirth. Aerys had dallied with mistresses
early on, but he came to believe the deaths of
his children were punishment for his infidelity.
When Rhaegar survived, he swore faithfulness to
his wife. However, he became superstitious, then
outright paranoid. He blamed failed pregnancies
on his wife Rhaella's supposed cheating,
imprisoning her under guard in Maegor's Holdfast.
As the Mad King grew vengeful and unhinged, the
Targaryen dynasty fell apart. Growing suspicious
that his one-time friend and Hand, Tywin
Lannister, was conspiring to overthrow him,
he married his eldest son Rhaegar to Elia
Martell of Dorne. The Mad King also became
obsessed with wildfire, using it to execute
his perceived enemies. He intended to blow
up the city should Robert Baratheon's rebellion
prevail. Instead, his Kingsguard Jamie Lannister
assassinated him before the message to
carry out the order could be delivered.
During the rebellion, the Mad King had his son
Viserys, and wife Rhaella — who was then pregnant
with Daenerys — ferried away to Dragonstone. He
kept Rhaegar's family with him at the Red Keep,
where they were all brutally killed
during the Sack of King's Landing,
along with Rhaegar himself. While Robert claimed
Rhaegar kidnapped and violated his betrothed,
Lyanna Stark, Game of Thrones
reveals they had actually married,
and that their baby — Aegon Targaryen — was
born out of love. Lyanna made her brother
Ned promise to keep this secret, and the
child was concealed under the name Jon Snow.
"You've never been a bastard. You are Aegon
Targaryen, true heir to the Iron Throne."
Robert became king and married Cersei Lannister.
Like Rhaenyra before her, Cersei had three
illegitimate children with her brother Jaime,
but none lived long enough to produce any heirs,
and the Lannister family line died out. Elsewhere,
Viserys and Daenerys Targaryen lived in exile in
the free cities. Daenerys expected to wed her
brother to strengthen the family line, but
Viserys married her to Khal Drogo of the Dothraki
to secure a large enough army to retake the Iron
Throne. When Viserys offended the new Khaleesi and
her people, they poured molten gold over his head,
killing him. Daenerys would give birth to a
stillborn son, and though she consummated her
relationship with her nephew, Jon Snow, he was
forced to slay her after she laid waste to King's
Landing. This left Jon — or Aegon — the last
hanging leaf on the Targaryen family tree.